meet Sarah and John Sarah is a sales
professional who schedules a lot of
meetings with co-workers and clients she
is also a tungle user John is Sarah's
client he uses different email and
calendar applications and is in a
different time zone when Sarah needs to
schedule a call with John she turns to
tungle here's how it works Sarah starts
a new meeting invitation she enters her
meeting details and selects J from her
contact list she clicks and drags over
her calendar to propose multiple times
for John because her calendar is synced
with tongle she knows right away what
times will work for her and when she is
busy John receives Sarah's email meeting
invitation and clicks the link he's not
a tungle user but that's okay he won't
have to sign up to reply and can even
respond from his smartphone tungle has
automatically customized the invitation
for John's time zone so he simply picks
a time that fits his schedule and clicks
book
meeting Sarah and John both receive
email confirmations and tungle
automatically adds the meeting to
Sarah's calendar John doesn't use tungle
but he can simply add the meeting to his
calendar from the email
confirmation and just like that the call
is
booked but what if Sarah had sent the
invitation and then added new events to
her calendar that overlap time she
proposed to JN tungle would have
dynamically updated the invitation so
that Sarah would not be double
booked and if JN ever wants to schedule
a meeting with Sarah he can use her
personal meet with me link that she has
added to her email signature and
Linkedin profile
he simply clicks the link can see right
away when Sarah is free and even send
her a meeting invitation proposing
multiple times without ever having to
sign up for an
account in fact Sarah saves so much time
scheduling with John that she now uses
tongle for group meetings too when she
wants to meet with her sales team she
simply creates one meeting invitation
and sends it to everyone it's easy
because she and her team share their
calendars through Tong
even though some of them work from home
and use different calendar
applications so when proposing times
Sarah simply selects her team from her
contact list and can instantly see their
availability overlaid on hers which
allows Sarah to easily proposed times
and ensures the meeting will get booked
quickly with group meetings each invite
gets a meeting invitation and chooses
all the times that work for them tungle
Narrows down the choices and the last
invite to reply simply chooses from the
remaining slots and books the
meeting and that's how scheduling is
faster and easier for
Sarah so are you ready to tongle